[Music]
well we've been spied on by the
biden administration there's not a lot
you can do about it you can make
noise about it and seem outraged but in
the end you don't really have a lot of
recourse you learn a lot about your
democracy when that happens to you one
thing you can do is file a freedom of
information
act request seeking any call records
texts or emails that the nsa got
from you or in this case us and so we
did that we haven't heard back from the
nsa probably won't for a long time
they didn't promptly respond however to
some stooge at the intercept which is
some
joke billionaire funded website this guy
filed a
foia request about our foia request and
then wrote on twitter this i've obtained
under foia the foyer request tucker
carlson sent the nsa
so what's interesting is and it really
does kind of crystallize the
total degradation of american journalism
the intercept was
founded to push back against the
the surveillance state was founded by
glenn greenwald and now of course
they're busy covering it up and cheering
it on
you wonder instead of foying our foia
requests
what are you going to find there nothing
why not figure out what the nsa
is doing the largest intel agency in the
world
that might occupy your time that might
be a virtuous thing to do
doesn't occur because of course they
support it and it successes
jonathan turley is a law professor at
george washington university he knows a
lot about the subject he joins us
tonight professor thanks so much for
coming on now i realize
the foyer requests from the intercept is
a lot easier because there's nothing
classified
that they need to respond to so
doesn't really explain why they filed it
in the first place if you're the
intercept
and you've got some creepy billionaire
paying the bills like why not get to the
bottom of what the nsa is doing
has that occurred to anyone
well apparently not a number of people
who have remained relatively silent the
people that you would expect
to be raising questions i just testified
in the house judiciary committee
on the surveillance of reporters and it
was one of the few times
in recent memory that there was
bipartisan agreement
with all of us who testified as experts
all the members in the room
agreed that we needed to fully
investigate whether journalists were
intercepted that has not been the
response to this story
now there's a couple of ways that your
emails might have been intercepted that
would be
lawful you could have been corresponding
with someone who is subject to an nsa
surveillance or that person may have
forwarded your email to someone who was
intercepted but it doesn't explain the
more troubling questions of
how that information was circulated
and also how your name was not masked
now you can unmask people on in a
surveillance document of that kind
but it requires someone to ask for
unmasking and there'd be no legitimate
reason to do so
here now if reporters were given that
uh information it would be even more
serious because
even if your email itself was not
classified
the intercept is nsa and foia material
is heavily classified i do national
security work
and it takes years for me to to get
access to a
to a fisa warrant i should say or an nsa
uh surveillance document so
the mere fact that they engaged in
surveillance
is classified so it would be a serious
federal crime
so yeah i mean why they're well i mean
because look they're
they're trying they intimidate people
the number of texts i got today from
people wow you know
everyone's afraid of the nsa and the cia
just to be totally clear
lots of people in the last
administration were really afraid of
them that's true i know firsthand
a lot of people now are really afraid of
them you want to live in a country where
people are afraid
of your intel agencies like what is that
why are we accepting this
well one of the interesting aspects of
this is a lot of people saying well
this would be ridiculous it's not
ridiculous as i testified
just about a week ago in judiciary there
is a
almost seasonal regularity to this that
is we have journalists
who are investigated in the bush
administration the obama administration
the trump administration
the biden administration and after every
one of those scandals
there's the requisite apologies promises
of reform
and everyone goes away and then the
cycle continues
right how about prison time i mean they
tried to set
speaking of run amok intel agencies they
tried to send roger stone away for the
rest of his life
for inconsistent testimony but none of
these people you know they thrive they
get msnbc contracts this is not
sustainable someone needs to fix this
for real jonathan truly i appreciate
your efforts on this i still don't even
know what your politics are but you've
been
you've been right on this for many many
years thank you
thanks tucker hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else